Hello.
My name is Rich Schwartzstein.
I'm from the medical school.
I'm a professor there.
And I'm a pulmonary
critical care
doctor who'd spend a great
deal of time doing teaching.
Part of the new curriculum
we've had there just
started three years ago.
And then something
called the Academy,
which is kind of like a Bok
Center for the med school.
About nine years.
In this session-- hopefully
you're in the right place--
about advancing and
promoting teaching.
And there's really two
pieces to this session--
to provide some insights
on how we support faculty
to be better teachers--
and that will be done,
I'm going to give you a quick
overview of that in the next 10
minutes; and then Julia Lee
from the school of engineering
is going to talk briefly
about how we provide faculty
incentives to improve teaching.
If you were in one
of the last sessions,
this notion of
misalignment of incentives
is a potential problem for
innovations in general.
And schools, perhaps
in particular, there's
the needs of the students,
the needs of the faculty,
the needs of the
organization, and how
you get those aligned
is an ongoing challenge.
So--
Rich, before you get
going, just to kind
of how we're going
to run this session.
10 minutes of presentation
for Rich and Julia
and a few minutes
of just clarifying
questions before we get to
a group activity at the end.
Thank you.
You're going to have a chance
to weigh in on the things you've
heard and other things
that you are thinking
about in your own schools,
and we'll go from there
in terms of discussion.
So improving teaching.
There's sort of two
approaches sometimes.
The fortune cookie approach.
Teachers work with the
curriculum much better.
It's sort of all about the
interpersonal aspects of it.
And that's important, but it's
probably not the whole thing.
And then there's the other side.
I will adopt best
practices, which
we've been trying to do
for however many years HILT
has been in existence now.
And talked about that on and
on and over and over again.
And I think it's a blending of
these two things in some way.
The art and science, focusing
on the science today.
So I want to talk
about how we can
get better and the role
of peer observation
as part of that process.
So this is from some
work of Anders Ericsson.
Some of you may know.
A psychologist
originally from Sweden
and had most of his
career in the US.
And he talked about
looking at something he
calls "deliberative practice."
Some people call
it guided mastery.
And this notion that
just because you
do something for a long time
doesn't mean we get better
at it, that you
need to reflect, you
need to have other people
helping you to do better.
And he's done this
work with everything
from chess players
to radiologists,
looking at the same thing.
And he talks about this
notion that as we get better,
we can plateau at a
number of different levels
depending on whether we
continue to do that reflection
and get feedback and act on
the feedback and so forth.
And even though these everyday
skills become very automatic
and we sort of like
that sometimes--
we don't have to think
about what we do,
it's just kind of built in,
it's habit, and so forth--
that doesn't allow
us to continue
to get better and improve.
It goes to this arrested
development stage, and then
ultimately, ideally, up
to expert performance
if you, in fact, continue
to reflect and get
feedback and work on it.
So there's a lot
of stuff going on,
I think, in education
generally right now--
very much certainly at
the medical school--
about the role of coaching.
And we probably know coaching
brings to mind many images.
There are a lot of personal
coaches that help individuals
in terms of work-life
balance and figuring out
how to navigate their careers
and those kinds of things.
And of course, most
of us had experience
with athletic coaches at
some point in our lives.
And what is a coach?
It's usually a close,
personal relationship
with an individual,
and that person
has the freedom to really
observe you, make comments
about things that
you could do better.
And then you work on that,
and you get observed again,
and that's, again, leading
up to that expert performance
kind of with that
guided mastery notion.
And so what we've tried to do
is blend this idea of coaching
with a peer observation program.
So this notion is
that teachers like
you will come and work with
you, watch you, and give you
feedback on things that
you're doing quite well
and things that maybe you
could do a little bit better.
And so this is a
list of the sorts
of things that are built
into this notion of peer
observation.
Now it sometimes
feels like you're
under the magnifying glass.
And when we first talk about
that with people there's
a little bit of, I'm
not so sure I really
want somebody in my
classroom watching what I do.
What is that going to feel like?
But the reality is people
can get used to this
and wind up finding that it's
very helpful, whether it's
about looking at specific
pedagogical approaches.
In fact, practice giving
feedback to each other
is good because it helps
you to give feedback
to your learners,
which is a challenge
for a lot of our faculty.
Allows us to document
our teaching activities
better and so forth.
All these things
that you see here.
And the reality is
we think everyone
can learn to become an
effective peer observer.
Now, doing this often depends
on developing these skills
in a formal way,
and I'll tell you
how long we've been doing this.
This is from a symposium
we ran at our Academy
at the med school in 2011.
So we've been talking
about this for a while.
We've had an interest
group, in fact.
We've been working on this.
We've done research
on some of the ways
of thinking about and doing
peer observation as well.
And it has taken us seven-- we
implemented it a year ago, so
six, seven years to really
get the program formally up
and running.
So it does take time
to get into this,
but I think it can
be very helpful.
Our new curriculum
is based on something
called case-based
collaborative learning.
And so this new format, which is
a blend of team-based learning,
case-based learning, a little
bit of problem-based learning
kind of all rolled into one
fusion for the medical school,
has specific elements
about how you do it well.
So we had a group that
got together and said,
what are the key parts of
teaching in this new format?
And we've actually published
as well the same kind of thing
for lecturing a few
years ago that we've also
used for peer observations.
So starting out
with an instrument--
and I think we've handed out
one of the papers that has
an instrument embedded in it.
Starting out with an
instrument is really helpful
because that instrument
helps you to think about
your teaching, just
looking at the instrument,
and it helps you make more
objective observations
of what you're looking at.
So it's very helpful.
When we started talking
about peer observation,
doing this with our
faculty, it was actually
quite well received.
In terms of using this
worksheet, most people, 73%,
thought it was extremely
helpful or helpful
in identifying and discussing
new teaching techniques.
So again, even after we had
done faculty development
for this process,
the peer observation
enhanced the faculty
development that we
did for teaching
in this new format.
And 90% found-- you can
see-- that the observation
debriefing was either
helpful or extremely helpful.
So this notion,
again, that I'm now
getting feedback that's
actionable, that's
tied to these specific
elements that we think
are important for the
teaching, turned out
to be very productive.
In terms of setting this up
there are different models.
This peer review
model, which is kind
of what the observation I've
been describing is about.
It's a discussion about
teaching mutual reflection.
And frankly, having been the
observed and the observer,
you learn a lot often
by being the observer.
Wow.
That was a great thing
that that person just did.
I'll incorporate that
into my teaching as well.
So it isn't just
the person who's
providing the initial feedback
who benefits from them.
And at this point, it's
viewed as purely formative.
This is just about helping
you to become better.
And this developmental model,
in terms of competencies,
again, if you have a
more formal instrument
and talk about the
elements of competence
that you want your
teacher to develop,
you can do that as well.
And then the last one is
the revaluation model.
This is one we haven't
really implemented yet
but we are talking about it.
So as we think about
aligning those incentives,
how do we potentially
even promote, reward,
otherwise incentivize
people who make
education a focal point of
their career in the university?
This may be a way to do that.
People say, well,
I'm a good teacher.
Well, how do I know?
Maybe you're on a
promotion board,
or you're a
departmental committee.
How do I know you're
a good teacher?
Well, you say, well,
my students like me.
And that's always been brought
up as a suspicious thing.
The students, what are they
really evaluating when they
say that you're a good teacher?
So this is a more objective way.
We train our
observers sufficiently
that we feel like there is
inter-rater reliability,
they're using a
valid instrument,
that we could potentially
use this down the road
to help people get rewarded
for their teaching.
And we're not at that
level yet, but we're
building, potentially, up to
that implementation for them.
So quickly, I'll just summarize.
We all can be
better as teachers.
I think whatever level you're
at, we all can have better.
But without this
deliberative practice
we're likely, in fact, not just
a plateau, but to get worse.
One of the famous
sayings in K12 education
is, have you taught
for 30 years or did
you teach one year 30 times?
Have you made any
changes to the way
that you practice, if you will,
in terms of your teaching.
And peer observation not only is
a way to improve your teaching,
but frankly the interactions
with your colleagues
is a very rewarding thing
to engage in as well.
And again, can be used for
either formative or summative
assessment.
All right.
So again, just a brief
overview of part of what
we hope to deal with today.
Let me bring up
Julia's presentation.
We'll have her go through
this quickly as well.
And then-- sorry.
Go back to--
Rich, do you want to answer
any clarifying questions?
I didn't know if you
wanted to do it after both,
or we can do it now?
Just if they're
clarifying questions now,
and then we can have--
Questions about anything that
I've done in this overview.
How many faculty have been
observed or observers?
How many faculty?
And Barbara, what's
the number that you're
up to at this point?
This is Barbara Cockrill
who's the director of faculty
development at the med school.
We've done this in the
preclerkship curriculum.
So it's a classroom teaching.
And I think we're up
to about 45 people.
And the peer coaches--
we're sticking with the
coaching model to start with--
we have 12.
And we do this informally
in the clinical arena
in different departments.
But our organized focus has
been on this preclerkship
curriculum.
Other questions?
Other clarifying questions?
Just since you've trotted
the numbers out now,
can you give us some sense of
the proportions or percentages?
Denominator.
Yes.
Sounds small to me.
It is small.
But we have-- it's not as
small as you might think.
For our first year--
We have six classroom
courses in the first year.
And so every student has
to take every course.
So the entire class is being--
Core faculty.
--in each of the courses.
So it's probably about 40% of--
Of that first year--
Of the first year faculty.
Because you have that
ability to focus in.
Yeah.
Right.
OK.
And it's all been
completely voluntary.
I mean, people are
signing up for it.
And it's-- well, no, no,
it is totally voluntary.
And that's been one
of the challenges,
is to get people to
understand that it really just
is coaching and not evaluative.
OK.
So Julia, will you
take it from here?
Hello.
Can you hear me?
So I'm going to pan out
a bit and talk about--
give you a brief overview on
the motivation, design process,
its usage cases in
the recent publication
of Career Framework for
Advancing University Teaching.
I was actually part
of this working group.
The publication is a culmination
of a 3 and 1/2 year global
effort to develop a open
access tool for people
to assess, evaluate, reward
teaching achievement.
And really, I want
to use this platform
as well to hopefully spark
some conversation about
whether or not this is
actually relevant for Harvard
or different cohorts at Harvard
who we're actually depending on
for teaching.
So this slide is
meant to hopefully
impress upon you the rigor with
which this study was actually
done.
So it's led by Dr.
Ruth Graham, who
is actually a
professor at Imperial
College in mechanical
engineering and has
since becoming a consultant.
But the initial draft
of the framework
was informed by pedagogy
literature and education
literature.
And then it was sent
out with feedback
from experts to
university leadership
across multiple institutions
and disciplines.
And I wrote
"including medicine,"
because even though it's a
Royal Academy of Engineering
publication, it's really meant
to be broadly applicable.
And what I think
is more powerful
is the fact that it was
piloted across about
five different continents,
and all the schools
are actually listed here.
So the schools that
are actually listed--
institutions are
listed in parentheses
are the ones that gave feedback
as opposed to direct piloting.
But nevertheless,
these were who were
involved in providing the final
product that was published.
I was involved in two ways.
Since I was already
on the committee,
I had gotten the blessing, as
it were, from our then FAS dean
Mike Smith, and then also
the SEAS Dean Robert Doyle
to actually really think
about this framework
and give feedback in the context
of how I was thinking about it.
And in particular, in
the context of how do
we support non-ladder
faculty careers
who we're actually depending on
more and more for the teaching.
And then also directly for a
university in South America,
whereas part of the
senior leadership
and as part of that
effort we were really
redefining the structure
of the university.
And we used this
framework, in fact,
to inform on a dual promotion
track for the faculty
there for teaching
and research-based
or some combination of both.
So that's the context.
And certainly there was
a lot of emerging trends
for the motivation
for developing
this framework, certainly in
Europe and Asia and elsewhere.
As fees were actually
increasing for universities
whereas they used to be free,
there was more and more demands
now because they have to
pay for better teaching.
And then I think there was
some discussion about this
this morning that there's also
competition of online learning
resources as well.
Interestingly, also in
Europe and also Asia,
the governments are actually
linking studentships and fee
structures to
quality of teaching.
So there is actually
some linkage
to that that is actually
encouraging people
to make the change.
Encouraging strongly.
And certainly, I think,
last but not least,
is that there was recognition
amongst the working
group and external to it,
that even though there
is this increased rhetoric,
for lack of a better word,
for better teaching
amongst the faculty,
there is really little incentive
for really improving it
because as long as
you actually pass
some kind of baseline
teaching quality,
then beyond that your
promotion chances are really
tied to research output.
And what this framework
was trying to do
was to try to provide a useful
metric for evaluating teaching
achievement that overcomes
traditional barriers in terms
of not having necessarily
well-defined things
for these different levels.
And what is
particularly interesting
is that it ties the
successive levels of promotion
if you will to your
sphere of impact.
And then what the framework also
provides examples of evidence
for what those might look like.
So just briefly to show those.
One can imagine that at the
most basic baseline level
you're an effective teacher
and your sphere of impact
is going to be the students.
You're actually
thinking conscientiously
about how do students learn
and how to effectively teach.
If you wanted to go
up to the next level,
then that sphere
of impact actually
has to extend to maybe
relevance to the broader
institutional context or
that you're actually giving
mentorship to your colleagues.
With a third track,
as we're moving up,
we decided that we're
going to split those
into two different ways.
One is if you
continue to improve
the practice of teaching
and the sphere of impact
to extend to a larger cohort
and beyond the university,
but it also allows
for people who
want to do scholarly research
to also advance in this way
if they're doing
research on pedagogy
and other similar things.
And then, of course--
and then, of course,
the highest level.
And so obviously you're
not meant to read all this.
For anybody interested, I've
got the actual publication
that goes into the details.
But really, it's broadly--
one of the key things
was giving examples
based on all these piloted
schools of what that might
mean for the different levels.
And these levels can be
broadly separated into two
major categories.
One is the approach, which is
really due to the instructor
himself.
Some self-introspection about
your teaching as well as
your professional activities.
The impact part,
which is assessed
through both direct and indirect
measures of student learning,
as well as kind of what your
peers think about your teaching
to, for example, Rich's point.
And so just an example.
There was a number of
universities that have actually
used this framework
in different ways
to kind of put it into the
context of how it might work
in a particular
university, whether it's
to slice through this
in different ways,
or whether as a
metric for where you
want to be in terms of
assessing the different people.
So here, for example,
this is University
of Twente in the Netherlands.
This one shows that--
so for somebody
who chooses to have
most of their career
in an education track
there is a baseline
requirement for research.
But at the same time,
most of the promotion
is really going to be
tracked to their teaching.
And what's very
useful and interesting
about this framework is that, in
fact, this institution is also
tied to support structure
for helping these people
move up to the different
levels as well.
And certainly, I list
this as the Netherlands,
but in fact, the University
College London one looked also
very much like this.
So there's a lot of
universities that actually
use this framework to
kind of make changes
to their institutions.
And as I said, the governments
have really gotten involved.
So for example,
in Malaysia, there
was a national government
call that universities
had to develop some kind of
unified academic pathway.
And so a number of
universities have
been using this framework to try
to work that out collectively.
What's really amazing
is that, as a whole,
the Dutch government
and most of the Dutch--
some large factions
at the universities
have really kind of
embraced this to the extent
that the minister of
education, who actually was
on this committee before he
became minister of education,
has decided to actually put
money towards this grant
to say, we want better
teaching so I'm going
to invest in better teaching.
And so they've actually
mapped these different levels
that people can
apply for and get
recognized for to
these different tracks
of this framework.
And in the initial
run of this in 2017
I noticed that they actually
invested 6 million euros
into this.
And these were the number of
fellows at the different levels
that are being supported
now to actually improve
their teaching.
And so this was published
formally in April 2018.
Some 30-plus universities
that we know of actually
use this to inform or
enact changes in some way
in universities.
So there is this global trend
towards really recognizing
teaching more.
And then I want to kind of
bring us back to Harvard
with that particular context,
is can we use this framework
to incentivize
our ladder faculty
to be better teachers in
some ways and to support?
But more importantly, something
that I've been thinking about
is, can we actually better
support the non-ladder faculty
who we're actually
depending more and more
on for our teaching purposes.
So if we actually
look at these numbers,
they make up a pretty large
fraction of the faculty
that we're depending on.
And so if I were just--
this is obviously not
correct, but if I were just
to attempt to map that to
this particular framework,
this might be the level of where
we would actually place them.
But as I was interviewing
different people
in different
departments, I realized
that the expectations of
these different people
are very different based on
what departments they are at.
So I just wanted to
put that out there.
So really my question to you
is, is a modified framework
relevant for Harvard?
Is it useful to support
non-ladder careers,
or as a means to reward
teaching for ladder faculty?
And then how do we actually
support and incentivize?
And then, of course, the
goals today is really--
I think we want to ask
the question of this,
how do we support all faculty
to be better teachers here?
We're going to break out
into groups and discuss this.
And then, also, how
do we incentivize
this improvement in teaching?
And I'll just leave that up
about next steps in this study.
But I'll just leave it up
during the question session.
Clarifying questions for
Julia about the framework?
I just have one question.
Did you put any--
did the committee try to
look at dollars at all?
And you hear all the time,
well, research faculty
bring in overhead from grants.
Teaching faculty, if you
have these teaching faculty,
they don't bring in dollars.
Of course, they might
bring in tuition.
So I wonder if you
looked at money at all?
Not as a direct consequence
of what we wrote.
But I think money was
talked about indirectly
in that a lot of
universities actually
do depend on student fees.
So in that case,
this is where I was
saying that as student
fees are going up,
there was a demand
for better teaching.
And so I think really in
that particular sense.
But I think it was
more than we recognized
that better teaching
was a need and there
was no support for it.
What a lot of the
universities have done
is actually invested their own
dollars in supporting this.
So the university said,
this is an important thing,
we're going to invest in it.
The problem is that
oftentimes it's
where this is an
important thing,
just do it along with
everything else and whatever.
So I think that was
something that we
were really conscientious of.
And a lot of universities who
did this really did invest.
So I just have a
question, and this is only
based on having taught
in Europe for a while
as well as having worked here.
I'm wondering if you've seen
any differentials in terms
of national culture with regards
to how quickly universities
and teachers are
picking this up?
For example, the
Netherlands for a long time
was way ahead of
the rest of Europe
in terms of emphasis
on teaching,
emphasis on experiential
learning, active learning.
And because they're
national systems as well--
they're primarily public system
versus the US' privatized
system--
have you seen any
differences in terms
of how large institutions,
like governments in Netherlands
or the EU versus other systems
like the US, are supporting it,
and how is that
affecting adoption rate?
So I think with the Netherlands,
I mean, it's really amazing,
because they decided
to take this--
I mean, to begin
with, all faculty
at universities
in the Netherlands
actually have to have some
kind of teaching certification.
So they already have to
go through that training.
So it wasn't that much
of a jump to enact.
But in terms of other
institutions-- so for example,
Cambridge, Oxford,
I was just there,
they were kind of resistance.
They're kind of like us.
But in that sense, the fact that
the UK government are saying,
OK, you're going to get a gold
star, silver star, bronze star,
and what star is going to
affect what students come.
And you could argue, OK,
well, Cambridge, Oxford,
it doesn't really matter
because people want that.
But the thing is that
what they've also done
is tied it to how much
you can raise fees
or whether you can raise fees
or whether the government
will give you any
studentships as well.
So that's how they're
actually really
kind of forcing the change.
Sounds like one more
clarifying questions?
So-- and you know, it's
not a clarifying question.
I'll defer it.
We'll come back to--
Mines sort of clarifying.
Was there a standard way
that effective teaching
was measured, or is
there a recommendation?
I think effective-- so we gave
lots of different examples
as part of that thought.
But I think that is something
kind of to be continued,
as kind of how do we--
how do you say, OK, we're
measuring effective teaching
when we don't necessarily know
how to assess student learning
outcomes, for example?
So it's meant to be a start.
So I think different
institutions
have their own definition of
what effective teaching is
at the different levels.
So it's left for those
institutions to decide.
But we kind of set very broad
guiding principles on this
is where you might be
thinking at at this level.
So we're moving on
to the workshop.
Well, what we
want, I was saying,
in terms of these
particular questions,
is to get a better
understanding of the interest
in supporting or incentivizing
faculty here at Harvard.
We're going to split the
room basically in half
and have you work in
groups to really answer
some of these questions.
One group, one part
of the room is really
going to really look at how
do we actually help faculty,
whereas the other part of the
group is going to look more at
how we can incentivize
faculty to be better teachers.
So we're going to talk in
our tables until 12:55.
And then we're going to
ask for one or two insights
from each of the tables.
But only one or two, so
you have to figure out
which are the most important
one or two things that will get
reported.
And we'll then
discuss as a group.
And we're going to be
floating around, eavesdropping
on discussions so we can see if
we can pick up some themes that
are being generalized.
So we'll start with--
which side should we start with,
the helping or incentivizing?
You guys had a
great conversation.
Can I start with you?
Sure.
OK.
So what top two points that
you thought were relevant.
So we were very interested in
the issue of both non-ladder
and ladder communities.
They're both very,
very important.
So in terms of
incentivizing, we think
for non-ladder, the potential
for retention and job security.
We're losing too many
people who are very, very
good at teaching because
there is a ceiling
to the opportunities here.
In terms of ladder
faculty, a couple
of big issues and also
places to incentivize
are around the issue of time.
Mismatched objectives--
the emphasis on research
rather than on teaching.
So course releases,
creating communities
of practice, that these
might be some ways in which
to incentivize the
ladder faculty.
And then we also thought in
terms of the faculty activity
reports that if you worked in
more questions about teaching--
and not just in terms
of individual practice
but also working in community,
so peer observation,
community as a practice--
that these might begin
to become things that would
be evaluated in terms of pay
raises.
Thank you.
So I think what we'll do
then is if these were some
of your ideas, try
to go down your list
and come up with ideas
that aren't on this list.
OK.
We had a kind of a
raging discussion,
but it's not as well
organized as that.
A couple of specific things
that we talked about that
seemed both like
helps and incentives.
Mainly the first
is an incentive.
It's the concept of a service
score for ladder faculty
that better incorporates
their non-research activities
and is part of the
promotion package.
And then something else
that we talked about
was something that is similar
to the curriculum fellow
model at the medical
school-- the idea of having
subject experts who are
also expert in teaching
to work with faculty to relieve
some of the burden of teaching
well and to make
teaching well easier
and to provide a good
opportunity for people
who want to teach to
do that professionally.
And we also talked about how
there's a ceiling on that
and that's a problem.
Great ideas from both tables.
We're still on
incentives over here.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
OK.
I am apparently
the spokespeople.
So a lot of the same
things that other folks
have already talked about.
And we also had a wide
ranging discussion
and talked a lot about the
tenure and promotion issues
at large that drive this.
But I think to add another idea
that, again, really requires
institutional level commitment
is to rethink teaching
as being the sole responsibility
of an individual faculty member
and think about teaching as
the mission of the university,
of the school, the department,
and think about restructuring
teaching so that the default
is teaching teams that include
specialists with a variety of
areas, that include the faculty
member as a subject matter
expert but other people
to take the time pressure
and just to redistribute what
teaching is
This group.
Thank you.
So I just want to say, sort
of expanding on the ceiling
conversation, in terms
of number one, what
would be useful in
providing faculty
with incentives, we
thought expanding
the definition of success and
just taking it to that level
and saying, how faculty
perceives success,
how can we expand that
as an institution to make
them see the value of learning
how to be a better teacher?
And then we also started
from number three,
what promising
practices do we see,
we talked about how the schools
are all sort of bubbling up--
the Academy being one of them--
where the schools
are really create
some promising
opportunities and centers
for where you can actually
learn to teach better.
And that's a
promising practice we
think that other schools
can learn from and continue
to go along.
Thank you.
Were you incentive?
Yes.
We were also incentive.
Sure.
So one idea that that
came up that we endorsed
was trying to make faculty
course websites and course
videos available to
colleagues as the norm.
And so if you wanted to take a
look at what someone else was
doing, it would be easy
to see their syllabus, all
of their course materials,
all of their lecture videos.
And just create a
culture of transparency
around teaching, where all
of our scholarly activities
are done very much in the public
and our teaching activities
electronically
can be made public
in a way that could
change the culture.
So widely sharing.
Are there any other thoughts
that we didn't come up
with here from these
other groups on incentives
before we move on to helping?
All right.
Let's move on to--
Can I say one other incentives
that I chatted about
with a few tables?
It's fun to teach well.
I mean, Barbara will tell
you that one of the biggest
things that we found
in recruiting faculty
to do this stuff in our new
curriculum was everybody said,
I've lectured, I've taught
this, this is the most fun
I've ever had as a teacher.
Doesn't always have
to be about money.
And so just wanted to
throw that out there.
And I think that the
community that we
have in our new curriculum
is an incentive.
It's not a monetary incentive.
But pointing that out to
other faculty, which brings it
to your point of sharing
and working together
with other faculty.
OK.
Let's move on to helping.
Are we staying on time?
[LAUGHTER]
So we also had a very
wide ranging conversation
that moved between
incentivizing and helping.
But where we landed
was really on supports.
And this almost goes
to transparency.
Making supports
for teaching truly
visible across all the different
levels of the institution
and making modeling--
the use of those supports,
making that visible from day
one.
And the example we used
was at the Kennedy School,
we have a new faculty institute.
Before faculty even
start, day zero,
they watch established faculty--
their peers, their
soon-to-be peers--
modeling innovative and
interesting teaching.
And that begins a cohort effect,
and it begins a conversation
that is helpful because
it demystifies some
of the practice of teaching,
some of the experimentation,
and it also creates more of--
I think it was to
Chris' group's point--
it creates a bit of
teaching as a communal idea.
It shows that teaching is
of value to the community.
Great.
How about you?
How did you decide to
help your teachers?
Was this the group that couldn't
answer all the questions?
[LAUGHTER]
So we agree with a lot
of what people have said.
Also focusing on a centralized
or collecting the community
of knowledge that's here.
There's a lot of
individual programs
and different departments.
There's Bok Center.
All the schools have
separate programs
to help their teachers.
But pooling those resources--
I admittedly have not looked
at the new HILT website.
You should look because they are
awesome It literally took years
and it's imperfect but
it is all there, I think.
I mean, hundreds-- hundreds
and hundreds of hundreds
of entries that are the
organizations and the tools.
And maybe to that point,
making HILT more broadly known
at Harvard.
Claudia was saying, what
percentage of the attendees
here are students versus
how many of the attendees
here are faculty?
And I know that
none of the faculty
that I work with of the 100
or so faculty that I know
and get along with,
none of them are here.
And so making these
researches more widely known,
including HILT.
So creating that
communication, it's not easy.
And it seems like
electronically we
have to all become
more facile, because I
know for us at the med school,
at the clinical part of the med
school, that feels like the
only way we can reach the 12,000
faculty that are at all
the different hospitals.
Was there another one?
Well, agreed.
I think a lot of people
mentioned a lot of the things
here.
But I just did want
to say that I think
we were thinking that
sometimes having champions
within the staff or
faculty to disseminate
this kind of information
is also important.
And another thing is creating
some school-based databases
of all the available
resources within the school,
whether that be different room
locations, or technologies,
or even people, so that it's
easy for separate faculty
to just access that and know
who to contact and who to reach.
And I think having those teams,
as that group had brought up,
with instruction designers and
all that dedicated towards you
is a great resource.
How about this group?
Thank you.
So I think we started off
by just kind of comparing
and sharing how our different
institutions approach
supporting faculty and
teaching assistants and really
folks at all levels.
And I think much of
what's been said here
is what we've discussed.
But really thinking about
support in a very systematic
way, starting with onboarding,
with mentoring, with the peer
observation, with evaluation.
I think for me a big piece
of that is also the culture--
the culture and the emphasis
on the importance of teaching,
and how do we make
it more visible?
So I think really a lot
of what everybody has said
has been captured here.
And then the alignment of that
with the incentives and really
making sure that they are
aligned, that there aren't
perverse incentives
kind of throwing off
the purpose of making teaching
a focus of the institution
as well.
And I think we have
one more table.
I saved you for last.
Thank you.
OK.
So we may prove to
be the rebel table.
But I'm going to
start with item five
because what we talked
about is that the assumption
that there's a need
to improve teaching
may be problematic for some.
Some may not see it.
And so in some ways mobilizing
at the grassroots level,
just start to engage everyone
in even why that may be a goal.
Otherwise, we're walking in
with a lot of assumptions
that create problems.
And it's troublesome.
It's difficult.
When we looked at number one,
what's useful for faculty
to improve teaching
practices, there
was a very good
suggestion in terms
of leadership being engaged in
real time effort and interest--
maybe coming to classes, being
visible in the many teaching
fora that exist in
some ways to start
to shake it up a little
bit and help everyone
shift their attention.
In terms of challenges,
obstacles, among many,
we came to the broader piece
of making the case for change--
engaging stakeholders.
Certainly incentives comes
up right away, but also
thinking about the many
metrics that we lean on
and their weaknesses.
I know it was mentioned
in terms of ratings,
and you had scores and things in
terms of for classes or courses
that we know are weak
metrics, yet somehow they
still live with us.
And so how we address
that, I think,
is a big issue that came
up for us many times.
Item three, promising practices.
We each came up with
examples and ideas
in terms of engaging
faculty and developing
the solutions, the programs, the
practices that then are going
to affect them as end users
so that, again, they're
part of the process.
And then number four,
in terms of supporting
at the department versus
school versus university level,
certainly it can
happen on many levels,
but the feeling of this
group was generally
that the department
level is part
of the core of where it needs
to start because there are so
many differences.
And it's not to have them
live in separate silos,
but then deciding how
they link may be yet
another piece of the process
we've just yet to learn.
Did I leave anything out there?
Nope.
OK.
Thank you.
Thank you, everyone.
Final to Rich.
Did you have anything to add?
So I had a couple of question.
How many people here
are on ladder track?
Oh, wow.
Interesting.
So relatively few.
OK.
And I guess we've talked
about the metrics.
That was obviously
one of the themes
that I heard listening in
in some of the report out.
At one level,
attendance, I think,
is a universal problem
in a lot of courses.
Faculty get upset.
People aren't coming.
There's something wrong
with the students.
But in terms of demonstrating
there's a problem,
I'd say, if they felt there was
value added they would show up.
I'm a big value added
person, that people
make decisions on whether--
between this and this
I can do two things.
Which one's adding value
to what my goals are?
If it's not adding
value they don't show up
unless it's mandatory and
there's a penalty for it.
So that, to me, is almost our
biggest metric that there's
a problem at some level.
And then I guess the
other question I have--
two other things.
One is the culture is
huge, and everybody
talked about the culture.
And all I would argue is,
don't be afraid to start.
I put that slide up
seven years ago when
we had a major symposium
at the med school
to start talking about
peer observation.
Seven years later,
we're implementing it.
We've got 40 faculty
in the preclerkship.
It takes time.
But if we had more
people with tenure
it'd probably be
easier to say that.
But anyway, it takes time to get
some of these changes in place.
And the one thing that we
play with a little bit in med
school, and some medical schools
across the country have it--
I don't know when it ever
would fly in university level--
is a Department of Education.
So you have your basic
department that you're in,
content sort of department.
But then for people
who are really
making a career as
educators, there's
a dual appointment in a
Department of Education
within the university setting.
And so it's another way
of recognizing people,
incentivizing them.
And there may be
some ways of getting
promotions and other things
through the Department
of Education.
But I just saw that as
a big picture solution
that, of course, would be
many years in the making.
But there are some models
for that sort of notion.
You already have a score.
Yeah.
I know.
We're just different than
a Department of Education.
All right.
It's different.
Little bit different.
I wanted to add something
about the culture.
I mean, actually, the next
phase of the study among some
of the subgroups or
universities is really
to try to do a longitudinal
survey study about really
evaluating what the
culture is for teaching
at a particular
institution, and then
cross-correlating that with
what the emerging trend is.
And so actually, if
anybody's interested in any
of this next phases, do
get in contact with me.
Thank you Julia, Rich, Barbara.
If you could just go ahead and
make yourself take one minute
and write on a card one thing--
it doesn't have to be based
just on this session
but from today--
that you would like to do
to change your practice.
Could be a long term
thing, could be right now,
could be from any point of view.
But one thing that
you think you would
like to do to improve teaching
and learning practice.
And I say this, like, we're
all ready to go have lunch.
But consolidating and forcing
yourself to commit to something
that you think you
might want to do
will actually make it
more likely that people
will go out and do things
and improve things.
And one final observation.
Peter, who's sitting here, we
had a conversation last week.
A faculty member deeply
involved with the School
of Public Health and a number
of educational initiatives.
But he's leaving
Harvard to go be
a dean at another institution.
So here he is, taking careful
notes, because now he's
going to be a dean.
He's got the responsibility
to think about.
So you just you never know
where these ideas that
might get reported
out could actually
go-- how many students could
be affected on the west coast
instead of on the east coast.
So one minute to just
write something down.
Thank you all.